Your body has trillions of cells in it, including
web-like neurons in our brains that help us
think, bundles of muscle cells that power
our movements, and electricity-conducting
cells in our heart that help pump blood around.
But, if we rewind far back enough, they started
out from the same thing.
The point where they decide what to be is
described as NOISY -- But how do they decide?!
Just like how people experiment with different
trends, and explore different types of music
when they’re young, our cells also go through
a bit of an identity crisis…
Just like how I dabbled a bit in a suburban
punk phase when I was younger, there’s a
point where our cells are deciding whether
they want to be a skin or heart cell.
At one point everyone was just a tiny single
cell, called a zygote or the fertilized egg.
The cell, which is about as wide as a strand
of hair , then divided into a few more identical
cells, and eventually some of these cells
began to deviate from their neighbours and
take on new identities.
A new study probed deeper into individual
cells in mouse embryos juuust as those first
few differences start happening.
This is like when the cells have been asked
what they want to be when they grow up.
At this point the activity in the cells is
described by experts as pretty “noisy”
… like the cells are throwing one last molecular
party before they commit to the . high-minded
life of a brain cell or submit to their future
in the colon.
This decision point is not super clean, and
even though it’s deemed “noisy,” it
isn’t actual sound…
It comes in the form of excess and seemingly
random transcription of DNA.
If you think of DNA as the set of instructions
- like a lesson plan your teacher writes on
the board - each cell only copies out the
instructions that are specifically relevant
to its functions.
For example, a light sensing cell in the eye
would copy parts of DNA that instructs it
how to make proteins that can sense light,
whereas a blood cell wouldn’t need those
genes.
Normally, each cell type has a characteristic
pattern of gene expression, but during the
noisy time all the cells are filled with random
bits of RNA, like a big mixer.
Then, they settle down and pick just the genes
they’ll end up needing.
Understanding this process has been a long
time coming.
Scientists have been speculating that cells
might have this noisy time for a while, but
it’s been difficult to observe experimentally
until recently.
Since cells are soo small and contain millions
of bits of information, it was difficult to
get enough material from one cell so we just
sampled them by the handful … but this means
we missed the subtle patterns and individual
differences between cells.
Now, a new technique called ‘single cell
RNA sequencing’ let’s scientists read
out which parts of DNA are actually getting
copied to be used by INDIVIDUAL CELLS.
It’s like we’re reading their little minds
and seeing what they want to be!
Based on this new information, its thought
this bursting of transcriptional noise gets
the cells ready to receive different instructive
cues from their surroundings, but there might
be other hidden signals in the noise we haven’t
quite made out yet.
More research is needed, but thanks to these
more sensitive techniques, scientists are
discovering new subtypes of cells every day,
and slowly getting a better understanding
of the road from fertilized egg, to the trillion-celled
masterpieces we are today…
Thanks for watching, subscribe for more videos.
If you want more examples of cells partying,
check out Julian’s video here about how
blood-brain barrier is like a bouncer.
One last bit: Noisy bursts were observed twice
in mouse development: once at the first cell
fate decision when 32 cells decide to be an
embryo or support structures, and again 3
days later as they specialize further.
Thanks for watching!